jennifer aniston admits reuniting with
her friends co-stars hit her harder than
she expected it was just a real oh yeah
and once her
gates opened then it was i couldn't shut
it off you couldn't even i could plug it
i didn't no nothing i i still was just
like jenny are you crying as much as me
she's like yeah
in fact it was so hard she says she
actually had to walk off of the reunion
special set after being reminded of the
quote hardest time in her life
oh god
the 52 year old actress opens up in a
new interview with the hollywood
reporter lamenting quote time travel is
hard and that they were all naive
walking into the experience quote you
get there and it's like oh right i
hadn't thought about what was going on
the last time i was actually here and it
just took me by surprise because it was
like hi past remember me remember how
that sucked you thought everything was
in front of you and life was going to be
just gorgeous and then you went through
maybe the hardest time of your life
oh hi
oh
holy crap
oh word all right well where's the
tissue box jen tells the mag quote it
was all very jarring and of course
you've got cameras everywhere and i'm
already a little emotionally accessible
i guess you could say so i had to walk
out at certain points i don't know how
they cut around it just please also
state that i don't cry like this when we
get together and have dinners you yeah
no jen never cries no no i don't
when asked what made her so emotional
she notes that while she worried about
her career quote it was more personal
stuff that i had expectations about that
sort of shape-shifted so to speak quote
but again everything's a blessing if
you're able to look at life's ups and
downs in that way and if it all hadn't
happened i would not be sitting here the
woman that i am there was something that
was
laid down at the very very beginning
that kind of went into our neural
pathways that we instantly it was in our
dna that we were family we were going to
take care of each other we're the most
grateful
women that i know who have been able to
be a part of something like this of
course jen starred on the hit nbc sitcom
from 1994 to 2004.
look at her standing there with those
yams
my two greatest enemies ross rachel
green and complex carbohydrates
during that time she tied the knot with
brad pitt whom she was married to from
2000 to 2005 and while she doesn't name
her ex as she reflects on those tough
memories she does say that her 2006 film
the breakup helped her deal with all the
tabloid headlines
i'm done
what i am done i don't deserve this i
really do not deserve this i deserve
somebody who gives a sh
jen asks quote is it a sliver of an
annoyance to have to publicly go through
dark in front of the world yes it's an
inconvenience but it's all relative so i
had a choice to make either i'm going to
surrender into bon bons and living under
my covers or i'm going to go out there
and find a creative outlet and thrive
and that's what i did
relationships happen and they happen for
a reason for
you know a specific period of time and
they're not necessarily meant to go on
forever the morning show star continues
telling the mag that as an actress she
was looked at as the girl next door the
damsel in distress and the brokenhearted
but she wanted to break out of that now
she says she's being offered a lot of
darker roles joking quote i guess be
careful what you wish for
stay excited and possibly something will
happen and the emmy winner she is booked
and busy for the next couple of years
with projects she's excited for it
almost doesn't feel like work quote i'm
just getting started i've only recently
started to be like oh i got this i think
i needed to get over those hurdles of
self-doubt and own who i am and where i
am and just how long i've been here
[Music]